the One Piece manga just revealed three
shocking things about monkey the dragon
Mega Punk and how a character that we
all believe to be dead pretty much
confirms the next destination of the
straw hats the man with the burn marks
that kid is looking for and since I
chose to go with a marine Admiral Dragon
for the thumbnail let's start with him
and why this chapter might give credit
to that very idea so Oda just gave us
the first proper flashback for Luffy's
father who has been an even more
mysterious character than people like
Shanks we see Dragon bringing a bouquet
of flowers to the charred and depressing
ruins of the island of ahara sometime
after the deadly Buster call had
devastated the entire Island and all its
people now seeing a 22-year younger
dragon is absolutely awesome basically
looks like Luffy with long hair and
Zorro's personality now interestingly
enough 22 years ago Dragon didn't yet
have his iconic tribal tattoo on the
left side of his face yet instead you
can see a very similar looking pattern
embroidered on his left pant leg and we
also get confirmation that dragon is
just about to found the Revolutionary
Army the very same year the incident of
O'Hara happened and it seems to Dragon
knew Professor Clover Robin's father
figure and the head archaeologist of the
islands now I think it's a super
interesting little detail about dragon's
past he seems to have had a real
interest in the void century and the
past we've pretty much always been
suspecting that Dragon would have a
decent amount of knowledge about the
Lost history and the ancient Kingdom but
the manga has now pretty much confirmed
this because this flashback is being
told not from Dragon's perspective but
from Dr vegapunks yes the smartest
person in one piece was also on a horror
the very same day also to lay down a
bouquet of flowers in memory of Ohara
and their work and yes we finally get to
see Dr vegapunk's real appearance and I
will say that this mock artwork that my
teammate from a while ago did hold up
surprisingly well but we we'll get to
that in just a second because of course
vegapunk's appearance holds a ton of
hints and Easter eggs that we need to
discuss in more detail but let's stick
with dragon here first now it was always
hinted at that vegapunk might have ties
to the Revolutionary Army the biggest
one of course being Kuma whom megapunk
program to protect and save the straw
hats and watch over their ship during
the time Skip and while he isn't an
official member we do now know that
Dragon actively tried to recruit him to
his Cause And while vegapunk decided to
work for the government in the end
apparently in order to get inside
information on their activities and
plans Oda shows us that these two men
seem to actually share a common cause
especially since we've seen the Vega
pankshaka in direct communication with
dragon here already now what is really
interesting here however is that in
spite their Mutual liking and shared
calls Vega Punk and dragon didn't come
to O'Hara together as a matter of fact
vegapunk is extremely shocked to see
Dragon there to which Dragon replies
well that's his line both of them feel
like the other shouldn't be on O'Hara
right now for some reason which brings
me back to the thumbnail could this
meeting on a horror be a hint at Dragon
being a former Marine or Cipher pull
agents after all there are a lot of
theories out there about just that the
world government making him the most
wanted person in the world and number
one threat to their rule going to such
extremes as putting him over people like
kaido and big mom suggests to me that
they know things about dragon and what
he's capable of that other people don't
Monkey D GARP his father is one of the
biggest names in the Marines who we do
know try to actively recruit Luffy Vega
Punk comments how dragon is someone who
despises war and in this chapter we see
another former Marine who was chasing
after the archaeologists only to try and
save them in the ends haguar di Saul who
is actually confirmed to be alive and
Well on elbaf will also get to that part
of course now Saul just like dragon is a
member of the d-clan former Marine who
became disillusioned with the government
and as we know Dragon doesn't want to
take down the Marines but the celestial
dragons which would make sense if he had
a lot of friends and you know Associates
there now overall there are a lot of
arguments for and against the
possibility of dragon being a former
real slash ciphopal member if that were
true though it would make a lot of sense
for vegapunk to react the way that he
does here if Dragon had betrayed the
government just a moment ago and was
about to found the revolutionaries well
he should really stay away from an
island that was burned to the ground for
its forbidden research so Dragon clearly
learned something about the true history
hence the meaning of his D initial from
these archaeologists and he even says
that he can't have Dr Clover's death and
the will of Ohara be in vain in other
words dragon has inherited the will of
O'Hara but you know it's pretty cool now
a really interesting detail here hidden
in the Japanese is that dragon only
founded the Revolutionary Army after
this meeting with vegapunk while
vegapunk is introduced as the head
researcher on Punk Hazard dragon is not
introduced as the supreme commander of
the revolutionaries as we now know him
but as commanding officer of The
Liberation or Freedom Army an
organization that we have never heard of
in one piece before now maybe this is
just an earlier version of the
Revolutionary army or it could also just
be something else entirely what seems
pretty apparent though is that the
Revolutionary Army were a direct product
of the Ohara incident Dragon decided
that he would do everything in his power
until every last person in the world is
subscribed to the O'Hara Channel okay
but what really was dragon's connection
to the people of O'Hara now it is
plausible that the dragon was simply
affiliated with Clover and got all his
information about the world from them
however I want to speculate you for a
moment if there might not be a little
bit more to that all you might know
where I'm going with this after all this
chapter also heavily features Nico Robin
and her mother Albia quite a lot
actually so let me just throw it out
there we don't know Robin's father right
we do know though that he must have had
black hair since albeas is white and I
think it would make for a ton of sense
story wise if Dragon was actually
Robin's father think about it I mean yes
the incident of ahara was cruel and
terrible and losing friends or
acquaintances would make you hate the
government but would that really make
someone who hates War as much as Dragon
suddenly form a militant revolutionary
group against the government itself well
losing your woman and child to the
government's craziness surely would
explain that pretty nicely plus laying
down the flowers would have an even more
deep and personal meaning than it
already does now the reason why the
godosei targeted Ohara was because they
captured Albia and her comrades at some
point could they have targeted her
because Dragon left the government also
remember that Dragon was incredibly
interested in meeting Robin and
instructed Kuma with sending her to him
the revolutionaries who helped Robin at
tequila wolf revealed that they had been
searching for her for 10 years because
she was the only Survivor from O'Hara
and dragon had told them to protect her
from the world government to the best of
their abilities now Robin being Luffy's
half-sister would be an absolutely
fantastic reveal to the story I think
Robin has truly been the older sister
Luffy never had but since there isn't
all too much evidence for that right now
let's really put it aside for now and
instead focus on Vega Punk now we've
already discussed vegapunk's affiliation
with Clover who by the way is revealed
as an adventurer like Nolan was in his
youth being captured more than 10 times
by the government for his archaeologic
actions now he has dedicated his entire
life to traveling around the world and
piecing together the void century and
now we finally also get to see what
vegapunk actually looks like and it's as
Oda as it gets among the army of quirky
characters he has drawn so far this is
one to rule them all I can never unsee
this Mega Punk seems to be part of the
same race that fukuro kuju belongs to
it's also the same head shape that we
see on the flag of the spice pirates
that annel encountered and there's also
a lot of rooms from speculation that emu
due to their strange placement of arms
and the relation to the top of their
heads might be part of that very same
race as well it does seem like these
people are all associated with extremely
high intelligence and technological
advances due to their large Brain as a
result it now looks like vegapunk is
actually since then split his brain into
six parts that he has infused into the
three robots and three I want to say
people that are part of his Persona it
also explains their personalities as
each vegapunk has most likely inherited
whatever function the original brain
part helps you know hunger anger so on
and so forth now I probably don't have
to point this out but vegapunk is of
course the spitting image of Albert
Einstein the genius German scientist who
developed the theory of relativity
especially the most famous photo of him
where he just sticks out his tongue
resulting in a permanent long tongue for
the original Vega Punk here and I was
kind of thinking that maybe this race
has an elongated head plus something
else I mean fukorokuju had elongated
earlobes for example now the brain split
thing also fits in very nicely into the
Einstein inspiration after Einstein's
death his brain was removed and split
into parts for further research that's a
real thing that they did and the fact
that vegapunk is covering up his head
with an apple-like thing is a nice
little knot at Isaac Newton and the
famous Apple that fell on his head that
made him to discover gravity also
gravity-defying boots in this chapter
just saying so it turns out that
vegapunk didn't only reverse engineer
the ancient Kingdom's technology from
stuff that he found lying around it's
really the fact that the scholars of
O'Hara actually succeeded in rescuing
the contents of the entire library from
the fire by throwing all the books into
the lake sacrificing all of their lives
in the process it seems and all of these
books were then collected by the Giants
of elbaf that do seem to be part of
hyrujin's crew if I'm not mistaken here
and it does look like the Giants of
elbaf are confirmed as another Ally of
the ancient kingdom here next to
shandora and wano something that we
already speculated and it is actually
here on elbaf that vegapung is truly
showing us his Real Genius he learned
all the knowledge in all of those books
here by heart and started to get to work
replicating its contents in other words
everything that vegapang knows about the
ancient Kingdom and devil fruits it's
all thanks to the research of the
archaeologists on O'Hara they figured it
all out by themselves the real Chads of
the one piece World in other words so
vegapunk is a Real Genius just not in
the way that we thought he would be and
he does seem to genuinely be a good guy
that has been waiting for Luffy though
we're gonna have to wait and see about
that let's not get ahead of ourselves
here I'm sure there are still a ton of
reveals left during this Arc that might
turn that entire thing on top of its
head though I do have a feeling that it
might be on the shorter end of things as
an arc overall I could kind of see us
moving on pretty fast from here but now
let's finally talk about the person that
saved all that Knowledge from O'Hara and
brought it all to elbeth Hogwart D Saul
is alive and it seems that aokiji hasn't
killed a single person in the entire
story he throws Luffy and Robin but made
sure they would survive same with
doflamingo and same with Saul as it now
turns out as well he didn't kill his
friends but instead probably saved his
life with the ice saving him from the
Flames of the Buster call also another
major hint I feel like that aokiji might
be working with dragon to infiltrate
blackbeards now we don't know if Saul
was severely burned by frostbite or by
the fire or the Buster call or both but
he is alive and seeing Robin's tears of
joy after realizing that might be one of
the most emotional panels since the time
skip in all of One Piece really that
that one really made me tear up now
given his Burns salt sounds a lot like
the prime candidate right now for the
man marked by Flames that kit is looking
for that allegedly has the last Road
poniglyph in his possession and that of
course makes a lot of sense for two
reasons one Saul as the safekeeper of
ahara's will the only people who could
actually read the pony glyphs he would
be a prime candidate to have a road
ponic lift it might even have been on
O'Hara originally and two we always
speculated that it would most likely be
on elbaf an island that most likely is
under the protection of Shanks that
makes elbav
99.999 the next Arc of one piece and I
discovered why Shanks is most likely
guarding the last ponig live there and
what will most likely happen during this
Arc if you're curious well make sure to
watch that video right here next if you
like